bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rtl france alors vous réclamer
l'annulation de l'élection du 31 octobre
à qui demander vous cela et bien déjà il
faut que nous mobilisions l'opinion
publique nationale pour qu'elle
comprenne notre combat et je dois dire
que nous estimons qu après le meeting
que nous avons tenu samedi dernier nous
avons pu constater que tous les efforts
de clarification de notre part avait été
compris par la population
si vous voulez je vais vous plantez un
petit peu le décor un parce que nous
disons que nous nous sommes de plain
pied dans une crise préélectorale avec
un processus électoral totalement bloqué
vous avez comme vous l'avez mentionné
d'un côté les tenants du pouvoir qui
s'accroche à un troisième mandat
nous nous répondre à cela que il est
anti constitutionnelle donc nous ne
pouvons pas accepter la candidature du
président ouattara eux se barricade
derrière la date du 31 octobre
nous nous disons que cette si nous
allons dans ces conditions là c'est
envoyer les ivoiriens à l'abattoir parce
que à ce moment là nous craignons
énormément une crise post-électorale qui
serait peut-être plus terrible que celle
que nous avons connue en 2010 parce que
nous avons pendant neuf ans du pouvoir
du régime ouattara nous avons accumulé
des rancoeurs d'aidé vraiment d'aider
beaucoup de choses dans dans nos coeurs
et nous disons donc que les conditions
ne sont pas remplies pour qu'il y ait
une élection apaisée et transparentes en
côte d'ivoire alors vous me direz vous
êtes une opposante alors à ce moment-là
peut-être que vos propos sont exagérées
moi je vous rappelle que lala comment
dirais-je la la la cour africaine des
droits de l'homme
donc qui est un organe de la de l'union
africaine a rendu deux décisions de
justice pour demander à la côte d'ivoire
de remanier la commission centrale en
charge des élections
de lui a demandé de la rendre égalitaire
et de réforme est également entièrement
les commissions électorales locales qui
sont totalement inféodée au rhdp nous
mettons en avant si la liste électorale
qui n'est pas crédible et nous avons
dénonce les preuves à l'appui un très
grand nombre d'anomalies et puis nous
avons aussi un autre problème se sont et
le non respect des droits humains et des
acquis démocratiques qui sont totalement
bafoués
on nous enlève le droit de manifester
d'exprimer librement nos opinions
vous avez des femmes aux mains nues qui
ont dû faire face aux chars de l'armée
parce qu'elle disait tout simplement non
au troisième mandat et c'est tout de
même un droit constitutionnel de pouvoir
dire ce qu'on a envie de dire
elle se retrouve en prison
arbitrairement
nous avons au mois de septembre 26 de
nos jeunes qui sont morts ce n'est pas
rien parce que eux aussi ils voulaient
se faire entendre et dire qu'il refusait
la violation de la constitution
alors pour nous oui pardon je rigole
presque on n'a pas beaucoup de temps je
suis désolé alors boulevard dont vous
demandez donc l'annulation du scrutin
admettons qu'il ne soit pas annulée et
que les élections ivoiriennes est bien
lieu le 31 octobre
est ce que vous appeler au boycott du
scrutin et il sera genevois ont même pas
à l'appeler il voulait par ce que il va
y avoir un immense nombre d'abstentions
à partir de là je veux dire la
légitimité de du résultat de ce scrutin
sera remise en cause
est ce que nous nous savons et c'est
cela que nous craignons c'est que le
jour est le mot au moment de la
proclamation des résultats
à ce moment là il va y avoir un immense
tollé et le peuple de côte d'ivoire peut
se soulever et après vous savez ce que
chez nous dans nos pays dans nos gènes
pays cela se transforme immédiatement en
une crise ayant une guerre civile
alors nous nous que ce soupçon non là
vraiment nous tirons la sonnette
d'alarmé
pour dire nous ne sommes plus au moment
des tensions maintenant nous sommes
vraiment face à une situation très très
grave qui en qui engage tout le devenir
de deux défis loiriens et nous nous ne
voulons pas que nos compatriotes
puissent partir à l'abattoir
je sais que et c'est malheureux quand
même que 60 ans après les indépendances
nous soyons encore incapable dans des
pays qui se construisent en tant qu'etat
démocratique ne soyons pas capables
d'organiser des alternances politiques
normales et que l'état fasse deux
témoins doivent toujours se faire dans
des conditions extrêmement tragique
nous le regrettons profondément alors
quatre candidats à cette élection
présidentielle dont le président
alassane ouattara
les trois opposants tout cas son accord
pour dire une chose que la candidature
du président n'est pas constitutionnel
est illégitime disent la même chose même
qu'ils sont unis le fini je ne fais pas
de qui vous parlez nous pourrions dire
qu'il ya là deux 2 qui sont unis c'est
le président bédié et le président affi
puisque ils font partie de ces deux
groupes font partie d'une coalition et
d'un trou de front uni de l'opposition
et c'est peut-être pour ça aussi parce
que traite depuis on nous a souvent
reproché d'être un peu trop et niété et
maintenant depuis quelques mois nous
avons constitué un front commun et
maintenant tout ce que nous disons et
tout ce que nous posons comme apte un
poids vis-à-vis de notre opinion et
aussi vis-à-vis des organisations
internationales qui défilent depuis un
certain temps en côte d'ivoire bon nous
espérons que peut-être il y aura un
certain engagement de leur part mais de
toute façon nous sommes nous conscients
que c'est notre destin c'est nous qui le
faisons et qu'il repose sur notre sur
notre volonté
moi je pourrais dire vous savez que la
date du 30 pardon oui suis vraiment je
vais ex je m'excuse des traits babar
maintenant nos régions je vous en ferai
ya plein
mais je suis désolé on est réduit dans
le temps en tout cas merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
danièle boni claverie je répète vous
êtes président de l'union républicaine
pour la démocratie en côte d'ivoire
merci